all right Diamond yes diamond where you
from originally where'd you grow at um
I've actually just been all around New
York I never really had a specific place
like I was born in Long Island and then
I came to the city when I was around
like
two um my mother wasn't really too
stable and living different living
conditions so I've just been all around
the city my entire life where was your
dad
what
Dad okay how would you describe your
childhood in
general
honestly it was good I say up until I
was around 6 or
seven um because then I started to
realize things and see things for what
it
was and then it just I was depressed
ever since what what did you realize at
6 or seven that changed you my father
left um my mother's mood was
very bipolar and um so your father was
around for a few years yeah but he was
in and out it was like he was never
there I can't even fully remember what
his face looks like and I only have one
photo of him and that's about
it yeah sucked any abuse or anything
like that going on in your life um it
was verbal
but I never really blamed my mom for it
I felt like she was just mad at the
world and I just happened to be there
so you you go to high school no um
actually graduated in
2017 I'm actually well yeah I have my
associates and I never
pursued anything else ever
since you graduated high school yeah and
you went to college it sounds like yeah
I went to a community college in the
Bronx and you've
struggled with mental health issues oh
yeah um yeah they diagnosed me many
different things um first it was anger
bipolar depressed then it was bipolar
depression and recently I was finally
diagnosed with Bard and law personality
disorder um but they're still also
looking into it cuz they might think I
have like a split personality it's kind
of hard to tell but what kind of things
have you struggled with
honestly just taking care of myself on a
daily basis I don't I can't really sit
here and say that I love myself or care
for myself even when I pretend to or I
try to I try to give myself like a
facade but
but it's not really what it
is what kind of things have
you done or have you been through that
would tell somebody that you have
borderline or anything else honestly
I've well I've tried to take myself out
in my own life a couple
times um it was about eight nine
times and
then just always going to the hospital
ever since
like
yeah and it's hard like this is the
longest I probably haven't been in a
hospital it's been
about 5
months are you on medications now or no
um my therapist had told me like there
was no real medication to help my
disorder and so did the doctors like I
would like to though but there's nothing
that exists but I've done tried at all
the
zolof dorine all of it and nothing
nothing
helped but I wanted
to like I want to be able to be
normal none of this is
normal so what what happens you you go
through times where you're okay and then
times where
you things get dark for you
and then there's times where I don't
feel like myself I don't even know who I
am half the time which is why they feel
like something in me is split cuz then
I'll feel like somebody else and
then there's times I'll go to sleep wake
up and I feel like a totally different
person with a whole new attitude that I
don't
like and it's
ugly I've lost friends I've never really
had family
and it
sucks I'm surprised I even have a spouse
you're married oh no boyfriend whoa whoa
spouse spouse is uh oh spouse is yeah oh
no I'm sorry I've been using the wrong
term this whole time um no
boyfriend of about 3 years or so yeah
it's been 3 years but we were friends in
the first year
but yeah I felt like he always
understood me even though there were
times where I've pushed him away because
of this whole
disorder what what how would you
describe borderline personality disorder
if that's what you have honestly it's
it's very
nerve-wracking knowing that there are
times where I feel super numb
and like just Everything feels surreal
it doesn't feel like I'm here at times
like even this morning like I had
trouble getting out of bed if it wasn't
for my boyfriend telling me yo you got
to get up you got to get
up I wouldn't had got up but
it's it's very
hard I don't think there's a word for it
it's it's
terrible and it puts you in a box like
it makes you it makes you stuck in that
box even though the Box might be open
it's like you know it's wide open but
you're still in that box thinking that
it's closed like you're stuck in it and
that you have no way out or no
options and I don't like
it do you feel like this was caused by
something that you went through as a
child or did you was do you have other
family members that are
similar I'm still trying to figure that
out out I felt like my mom was because
people often mistake bipolar disorder
with borderline personality disorder cuz
they're like neck and neck which is why
doctors always misdiagnose me and um I I
feel like some of my family members are
even if they don't know it cuz they
never really got diagnosed like they
should have I was actually the first
person to ever have therapy in my family
or want it per
se
what's been your darkest
moment my darkest
point it had to be when I got
raped yeah and nobody believed
me not my
mom not my
family some of them actually made fun of
the fact that I was
rape and it made
me it made me feel like
dirt and um and that's when I realized
maybe I don't really have a
voice maybe I don't need a voice and
then I tried to take myself out and then
I was in the hospital for about like 3
weeks to a
month how old were
you 17 16 17 yeah 16
17 and then I was shipped away to like
this
program um in Massachusetts it
was terrible that was a dark Point
too that they restrained people put them
in rooms restrain jackets electric shock
therapy
treatments cameras in the
bathroom
like I don't think nobody should ever
would be sent there
like I feel like it's worse than prison
and I've had friends in
prison I
hated like I ended up like having
bruises all across my body at one point
cuz of how many times they restrained me
like pin me to the floor held me down it
didn't matter if I couldn't breathe or I
cried it just didn't matter
are there times where you're okay and
everything is is good in your
life I feel like I try to pretend that
they are but they're really not because
I want to try to
live but I don't feel I don't feel it
anymore I I don't even think I ever did
feel it
like to me nothing was real not friends
not family there was nothing that really
kept me here and it still doesn't
like that's why I reached out to
you um I feel like your channel kind of
saved
me thank
you your channel
really seeing other people go through
similar things helps you cope with what
you're going
through sometimes I watch your channel
till I go to sleep
like there was nothing like like I'm
trying to find it I I can't find my
voice and right now you giving it to me
is all I cared about I didn't even care
if I got picked or not like I think I
just wanted to be heard not seen as some
weirdo or an outcast or pushed aside or
neglected like I just wanted to be
seen and I thank
you I think there's a lot of people
going through different forms of
similar battles yeah then I watched that
one girl um that talked about borderline
personality disorder and it popped up in
my YouTube as like a recommended I was
never even subscribed to your channel is
that Sheena I think I think so she was
very beautiful yeah from Detroit I think
so yeah yeah and the way she spoke about
it and I'm just like damn this is me
like my boyfriend said yo she reminds me
a lot of
you you're not alone n for the first
time in my life
yo I I felt like there was somebody
there
like you feel misunderstood all the time
all the time all the time like I
think that's why I try to take myself
out when I can but it never
works it's not like your behavior is
like you acting out and being a jerk
it's it's just what you can't help it do
at the moment
right yeah sometimes I feel like there's
no other option I'm still on that box
it's open but I'm in that
box and inside that box is voices
that'll tell me you're not enough you
don't belong here nobody cares about you
nobody loves you you're always going to
be misunderstood and it's on repeat like
and it's
there and I try to do anything to make
it not real
but it's it's always it's always going
to be there
like what age was it where this kind of
started taking hold
I think for as long as I can
remember probably like 5 six really
early yeah like super
early but because you know therapy
wasn't really a thing for people even
now like I'm
surprised at how much stuff is out now
like people talking about anxiety they
talking about all these mental health
problems when I was growing up this was
not allowed at all you talk about it
you're like grounded you're to the side
like I'm surprised when I used to talk
about it people look at me like I was
crazy how old are you now I'm just
turned 24 in August and I'm surprised
cuz I did not see myself living past
16 like I literally planned to not live
until the age of 16 like I had wrote a
letter it still sitting in my Google
Drive and
everything
like I'm I'm really surprised that I'm
still here and I feel so lost now that
I'm still here are you hopeful for some
kind of Remedy
solution some some different approach
that might
help
no sometimes I'll try to write
but then I get right as black or super
distracted did or whatever and I
just I close it off like I have probably
like three to four unfinished books in
my Google Drive just collecting
dust but no I I still don't know what
the I want to do I feel like I went
to college just to be there just to have
some sole purpose but do you have any
dreams or aspirations that you you like
to see happen in your
life oh you got
me I'm
stuck is depression part of what you
experience all the time
yeah I don't know what my day is like
without it
like constant I hear you laughing and
joking and yeah cuz that's the only way
I get past it like that was my coping
mechanism like like even when I used to
be in the
hospitals even some of the staff members
they would look at me like why the
are you here like you look so joyful you
look so happy people tell me that all
the time like even when I was coming
here I used to work um f over here um
like a block away and one of the old
co-workers I used to work with came by
the window like I recognize that joyful
Soul anywhere and I'm just like oh
like I don't know
laughing sometimes it's
forced sometimes it I can make others
laugh but weirdly enough sometimes I'll
be so
numb that I don't feel
it and I think fully that's why I also
reached
out cuz I don't want to leave this
earth not saying
anything not reaching
out not trying so I guess this is my way
of trying I didn't know it was going to
happen but cuz like I said I didn't
really care if I even got picked or not
as long as I gave it a shot as long as I
gave life a shot I think that's What
mattered what would you say is your your
greatest
strength what's your what's your best
quality
I
relate I relate to people and I don't
judge like I done heard the craziest
stories you think you've heard some
stories
Mar I done heard too much and
people confide in me
like at one point I thought I wanted to
be a therapist cuz you know people with
problems is often the people that's
better to be therapist I feel
you've been through it yeah even my
therapist she's been through it and we
relate like no other she's actually the
like the longest therapist that I've had
cuz I'm not good with
um keeping things I think that's part of
the personality
disorder like um I'm not good at keeping
a job keeping friends keeping
family but she's someone that I've kept
now for about four months four or five
months
but
yeah I wanted to be a
therapist but I can't help other people
if I'm still stuck this way
either what's your greatest
fear I don't think I have
one I've already tried death I
mean if it actually Happ and I don't
even think i' be scared of it I think I
just be
fine I don't
really have too many fears at first it
used to be being alone but then I live
alone I've always felt alone so I'm
already living my greatest
fear do you have moments where you're
feeling good everything is great and
you're not having these Suicidal
Thoughts
I feel better weirdly enough with them
like they're a part of me
like I don't know how to explain it it's
like I'm I'm living with different
roommates in my head they're not the
best roommates but they're there
and I'm here with
them I don't know it's it's not a
sensation but
for me it's not the worst I don't I
don't think I've ever had a day where
Suicidal Thoughts never passed by even
if I'm at a party or I'm out to eat with
somebody or sometimes even with my
boyfriend
like they're
there at first I used to hate it but
then I've learned to live with
them yeah
do you have
siblings
yeah I got a younger sister and a older
brother who I call my older
sister we're not all close I don't
really I wanted to be but they've you
know how they say that your family is
like the people that probably hurt you
the most well
they've hurt me the most push me
isolated and now we all just don't
talk did your
friends
oo I
mean I have like a guy best friend he's
one of the greatest people ever like
when I first started going to the
hospital and everything he was always
there or mostly he was always there cuz
there was times I went to the hospital
he and them you
know he's always been there even when he
didn't have himself he had me and even
now we're kind of
distant and it sucks it feels like he's
not here anymore but I know that's not
the case but the disorder makes me feel
like he's not
there but no I don't really got friends
if I did they all abandoned
left or scarred me then left
me
yeah Diamond what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your
life do what the you want to do
people are going to judge you no matter
what it is do what you want like live
how you want to live dress how you want
to
dress be who you are like I wish I could
be who I am fully I'm still learning
that that's that's my
advice all right Diamond thank you so
much for sharing your story thanks Mark
I wish you lots of luck with thank you
so much whatever you're struggling with
thank
you
that